et puis la semaine dernière on se met
bernard montiel et laurent a fait un
petit canular on a appelé au nec qui
vendraient sur leboncoin.fr le livre de
bernard montiel à 3 euros et laurent
essayé de négocier un euro et le vendeur
a pas voulu et grâce à nous finalement
le vendeur a trouvé preneur grâce à
twitter il ya virginie qui nous dit
j'achetais le livre c'est moi qui lui
donne 10 euros un grand merci à tirer
et nous on a envoyé nos livres ouais
allez vous rendez compte à la base ils
le vendaient 3 euros et quand même 10
euros ici on trouve nos bouquins sur le
bon coin là mais conservez vous
voilà donc en tout cas quand vous avez
une merde à vendre dites le nous bras
salut les terriens vous pouvez faire 200
pour sylvie nève
[Musique]
d'ailleurs resté cinq minutes parce
qu'on n'est pas la brique qu'on fasse un
truc à la fin de la chronique ah ouais
et ça peut tomber sur n'importe qui
notre premier invité thierry c'est
madame la comtesse pascal de la tour du
principe
[Applaudissements]
c'est là c'est la deuxième conquête pour
soi cette année après massimo gargia
qui devine pas ce qu'est la tour du pin
et encore ça c'est la version courte
parce que la version longue c'est pascal
de la tour-du-pin chambly de la chasse
de bfm tv du groupe nextradio de patrick
drahi et non mais pascal et prend
l'antenne tous les matins à 6 heures du
coup le temps de finir son nom il est
18h45
[Musique]
bfmtv c'est la première chaîne d'info de
france voilà et détiendra bfm tv et sur
place soit là pour faire une interview
des voisins ça fait quoi de connaître
tous les voisins des plus grands
criminels de france c'est vrai que bfm
va être partenaire de la fête des
voisins bientôt
[Applaudissements]
à la nôtre deuxième invité beaucoup
pensent que c'est l'inventeur du chat
[ __ ] et c'est faux lui c'est le shaq us
et patrick sébastien
déjà je tiens à le préciser c'est
toujours un bonheur de recevoir patrick
sébastien on l'a reçu à quoi il ya six
mois on a reçu
patrick on a reçus nagui et drucker
voilà si on doit recevoir que les mecs
qui font l'audience sur france 2 ça va
tourner vite
et là vous venez pour une nouvelle
chanson ça s'appelle barracuda
le barracuda ça c'est l'impression il ya
quelques années peut-être que vous
auriez fait une chanson sur les moules
mais du coup on sait que c'est l'album
de la maturité
alors j'ai les pièces première ligne des
paroles de la chanson moi c'est là là là
là on est au lala aux egos et franck
ribéry et qu'il est parti
on se montre pas parce que patrick
sébastien il a vendu trois millions
d'albums c'est quand même énorme main
dans toutes les grandes occasions il y a
du panache de bastien dans les mariages
c'est ont fait tourner les serviettes à
ce stade dans les divorces et si tu
pouvais fermer ta gueule et dans les
enterrements c'est là qu'est ce qu'on
est serré où cette boîte
sympathique équipe patrick mevoungou
rien c'est un chanteur très populaire et
vous avez dit je suis un chanteur
populaire méprisé par une certaine élite
alors si c'est l'élite qui planque son
argent pour pas payer ses impôts on s'en
fout en revanche hissée l'agencé élite
de mannequins la simplifier
[Musique]
et puis pour terminer tirer notre
troisième invité champion du monde 98 il
a joué dans l'est dans les plus grands
clubs il a perdu ses cheveux on sait pas
si dan c'est christophe dugarry
alors on est plus beau comme ça ouais
mais c'est enfin bien s'en remet à jason
statham je trouve merci j'aurais
vraiment on sauve qui roulent en fiat
punto
blanc christophe dugarry s'est
évidemment voilà le champion du monde 98
ça vous fait quoi de savoir qu'il ya des
jeunes qui étaient trop petits pour
faire du rock ont pas vu le match à
l'époque je pas comme emmanuel macron
par exemple les enfants si
les enfants ils installent de plus qui
force enfin christophe ça c'est la
classe le stade christophe dugarry voilà
michel drucker il a un cimetière et non
non je crois qu'il va y avoir aussi
bientôt la déchetterie patrice evra
vous allez en parler tirent il ya eu un
petit accrochage avec patrice evra enfin
un accrochage c'était généralement
contrer la portière patrice evra là il a
rayé la portière il a pété les rétros il
a tordu les essuie-glaces et la chier
sur le capot
quand il était joueur il ya deux options
soit coach soit consultant mais comme
coach pour passer des diplômes
voilà et
non
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai il ya
plein d'exemples de reconversion et à la
con dégâts non c'est non c'est non mais
c'était
alors au boulot tu sors je pense que
j'ai parlé à
échanger des idées ouais d'accord si je
comprenais pas non mais ça c'est les
bonnes trajectoires moi y'a juste un
truc que je comprends pas c'est dans les
reconversions pourquoi plein de footeux
ouf des bars ou des restaurants ouais
jamais géré mangé dans le restaurant
d'un footballeur pourquoi déjà sur le
terrain il crache tout le temps alors
dans les cuisines j'aurais
[Applaudissements]
juste pour terminer la semaine dernière
je dédie au début la chronique ou
recevait bernard montiel laurent il a
appelé quelqu'un sur leboncoin.fr pour
acheter le livre de bernard montiel qui
était à 3 euros et tu t'es un peu moqué
laurent et j'ai trouvé le livre de
laurent à 2 euros au plus tard les gens
sont vraiment dans la merde
on peut essayer d'appeler cette personne
pas s'il vous plaît en régie
alors oui bonjour monsieur c'est
concernant la petite annonce que j'ai vu
sur leboncoin.fr est pour le peuple et
non pas du non pas du tout c'est pour le
livre de laurent baffie le dictionnaire
il est toujours à vendre ah ouais ouais
et vous l'avez lu il est bien
d'accord et est ce possible de baisser
le prix de le baisser à 1 europa
bon ben c'est gentil mais je vais vous
le prendre alors tendez jeu juste vous
en voyez combien
attendez je joue je vous passe l'auteur
du livre je crois qu'il a quelque chose
vous dire bonjour monsieur bonjour
pourquoi vous le vendez ce livre il est
formidable pour laisser dans les
toilettes oui georges et trois quarts
comme donc je
sais comment ça se fait que vous avez
trois cartons bah en fait t'es pas que
je suis le fils bloqueurs du coup les
bâches 1
j'ai pas reconnu ta voix ouais c'est le
baiser
mais ta promo monfils finit que tu joues
à la grande comédie tous les soirs à
21h30 que je te jure toc toc vas-y fais
ta promo monfils ouais bah voilà
[Applaudissements]
super quelques parcelles jamais merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu